there's lots of uncertainty throughout
the bitcoin market we continue to watch
the price fluctuate right around twenty
thousand dollars but the big macro
picture we see the federal reserve
raising interest rates and everyone
wants to know how will bitcoin survive
during its first true recessionary
period my hope is that these weekly
updates help to answer some of those
questions and don't forget this weekly
update is now brought to you by ftx us
you can click on the link in the
description to learn more let's jump
right in and start looking at the
bitcoin network itself we see that
bitcoin's price trading just above 20
000 as of yesterday up about 1.68
if we look at the network we can see
that the market cap of bitcoin now sits
just below 400 billion dollars the
inflation rate is just under 2 and more
than 90 of the 21 million bitcoin is now
in the circulating supply the real
exchange volume for bitcoin sits at 4.6
billion dollars in the last 24 hours and
the miners have been paid just under 19
million dollars to continue to secure
the bitcoin network we see that bitcoin
is down 70
since the all-time high of 69 000 back
in november if we then take a look
bitcoin is down 36 over the last 12
months gold and the s p down as well but
over any other time period two to ten
years bitcoin has absolutely dominated
these other assets bitcoin closing
history shows us that for 547 days it's
traded above where we are today and if
you bought bitcoin at any point over 89
of bitcoin's life and held it till today
you would be in profit we can see that
bitcoin's compound annual growth rate
compared to gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt
the compound annual growth rate of 117
percent is absolutely destroying these
other assets that five year sharp ratio
of 1.05 also means that bitcoin
continues to be a positive addition to
many people's diversified portfolios now
if we just look at the bitcoin network
it tells us one story but of course we
need to go look at the on-chain metrics
will clemente and the team over at
blockwear do a fantastic job every
single week let's dive into the metrics
they shared this week will points out
that the miners are very pro-cyclical
forces in the bitcoin market he says
that they hold their bitcoin in the bull
market and place orders for more
machines that have a delay from when
they were bought to when they're plugged
in for a variety of reasons including
manufacturing and shipping times and
building out shelf capacity for the
machines to operate due to this
hashrate's cyclical peak has
historically lagged the peak in
bitcoin's price then he goes on to show
the bitcoin mean hash rate the 14 day
moving average and he says the machines
continue to be plugged in at an
aggressive rate throughout the late 2021
and into early 2022 but the bitcoin spot
price has declined by roughly 70 since
then and so there's a new variable
adding to the compression which is the
increased energy cost driven by supply
chain issues will's been tweeting about
this for a while if we go back to june
18th what we see is that he said lower
bitcoin price higher hash difficulty and
higher energy costs have put serious
pressure on miners margins hash price is
now its lowest since october of 2020.
the hash ribbons have crossed indicating
machines unplugging and miners sending
bitcoin to exchanges then we can go take
a look at the hash ribbon and what we
see is the juxtaposition of the 30-day
and 60-day moving average of hash rate
to create a proxy for momentum moves in
minor dynamics
next up we can see that the minor net
position change shows that miners they
were selling some of their bitcoin it's
cooled off a little bit but that doesn't
mean that they won't pick up again as we
can see from this chart here the public
market has punished these bitcoin miners
and the thought process is that if
bitcoin's price was able to recover
these miners likely would follow as well
it tends to just be higher beta bitcoin
exposure but history may only serve as a
guide doesn't necessarily predict the
future i hope that you enjoyed these
weekly updates on bitcoin i learned a
lot by putting them together it's also
great to have people like will in the
blockwear team doing so much analysis on
the on-chain metrics and looking at
things like miners exchanges and the
various market participants if you're
interested in bitcoin you can head on
over to ftx us ftx sells bitcoin at
sometimes as much as 85 cheaper than
their competitors on transaction fees if
you're interested go into the link in
the description click on it sign up and
see what it's all about ftxus they
continue to work on getting best pricing
they're adding things like digital
stocks and beta and they continue to try
to innovate around all sorts of
financial markets that's it for this
week hope that you guys enjoyed it and
learned something i'll see you guys next
week